the sexiest man alive black Superman
which one do you like better
uh sexiest man okay yeah you know cuz
you know alive you know black Superman
he's got kryptonite Yeah right so you're
not gonna you're not gonna release that
moniker wouldn't be when they name
someone next year that's sticking with
you
well apparently you mean success it says
sex is man alive as long as I'm alive I
am the sexiest that's what Dwayne told
me to say earlier oh really that's what
he's running with alright bro keep it up
you know it no more
okay you got me back here to London
which I thank you for so my question is
we're having these dueling junket why
are the Brits better at junkets oh just
why are you all better you got me here
dancing with you it's really nice you
know you know we think it's better than
you you know you come to London because
London is a big backdrop in the movie
yes indeed and you know you can see that
you you know you've got my cars here and
my little one in the corner they'll all
cannon that's mine too and you know we
wanted you to dis experience the cobbled
streets of England last time I talked to
you though I hadn't seen this movie oh
that's nice thank you you might but
actually you're not gonna fly to London
if you didn't enjoy there you go you go
I really really loved it and I wonder
how beat up do you really get on a movie
like this what's your body like on any
given day uh well you know aches and
pains mainly you know because those
fight sequences you know the way David
Leitch likes to shoot he's like five six
moves at once you know typically you go
punch cut kick cut he's like punch kick
and but duck roll run come back kick
again and cut and so by the end of it I
just want my bed you know do I ever
body that the person that he lifted over
his head and body slim was actually you
that's the story that that's the word on
the street
Oh Wayne you know doing let me tell you
something buddy
when you finish being an actor you could
be a comedian ha ha
okay buddy he put in a room is that day
because you're saying get you on the
street one on one if you don't fight
well especially in London yes Wayne that
one every meal in Hawaii oh you know
Florida he might have the upper hand but
here hmm
I heard that he said you don't want that
smoke going as a warning okay I want to
play a little spring round okay okay
I'm terrible at this sort of things and
let you know now no you're gonna be good
okay I'm gonna claim this for you we're
gonna put positive energy at this half
of the battle like it okay this is kind
of pulling the curtain back on two of
Hollywood's kind of toughest guys Dwayne
and Jason okay good so which one of
those tours is the biggest softly softly
yeah definitely Dwayne pull the curtain
back Dwayne he's a real softy like he's
uh you know you've seen him you know
he's just a nice warm cuddly kind of guy
he looks tough but he's in it but he's
not okay who goes harder in the gym ah
definitely Dwayne Dwayne goes really
hard hard it in anyway have you seen leg
day it's crazy
oh I haven't seen it his leg days are
crazy oh wow is that a thing here's a
leg day a day yeah cuz most of us do ten
minutes on legs he has a whole day whose
head is shinier I do you know what I'm
sorry I just don't look at the head hey
you know I don't be like hey man yo yeah
I just don't have you know I have no I
have known so the necessary saw her
reflection in both of them Wow
nunu when I known you guys boy okay so
who would win in a real fight in a real
fight between me and Dwayne or me
Jason enjoy your money my money's on
Dwayne because he's just bigger but let
me tell you this Jason ain't no slouch
he's a martial artist he is and he's
nimble and he's vicious
see and he can hold his breath for a
long time because he's a he's a diver
so if Dwayne got him into a chokehold he
so and if you're quicker and nimble he
might need some pretty boy stuff you
know okay I wanted to ask you real quick
cuz I have you here cats trailer dropped
oh yeah where did you think about the
reaction everything with it wow you know
it's interesting because I'm starting to
understand the wave of the reaction
everyone seemed to really fascinated by
it and then it's great because you know
we put everyone the director the cast
put their heart and soul into that thing
so I'm really pleased that people are
excited by it it's a spectacle I can't
wait for people to see it I love the
behind the scenes of like looked at
interest like really doing content
listen you know when you're playing a
cat by the way this is not the first cat
I've played okay all right I'm really
excited yeah that's the first time I've
done a musical on film so yeah meow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]